[Music]
okay well tonight we're gonna go over
just tactics in particular the subject
is double attacks last week we went
through another tactical concept of
pinning so this is an extension all
these examples are taken from Siebert
cherish's book the game of chess he
copyrighted it in America in 1935 the
young boys who sometimes come and watch
these sessions aren't here tonight
because it's Halloween so they're out
playing all right well we'll jump right
in so double attacks what you look for
you look for unprotected pieces and the
you try to attack two pieces with the
Queen or a bishop rook or Knight
sometimes they're called Forks
since you're attacking two pieces they
you usually win one unless one of the
pieces can move and protect the other
one or the other defenses if there's a
strong counter-attack so you don't
protect the pieces you get your own
threat of maybe threatening a checkmate
or another major threat that would be a
defense so we'll start out with some
pretty simple examples this one's pretty
simple who see LK it's white to move and
win it's only one move do either of you
two guys see the winning move well let's
put it let's look at it this way
remember we're looking for unprotected
pieces what are blacks unprotected
pieces in this position
yeah and the other unprotected piece
which pawn Oh f7 yeah that's unprotected
and the rook
I think we're focusing on pieces this
time rather than pawns in this example
anyway okay so there's a rook on a right
and there's a bishop on e7 ones on a
black square ones on a white square now
that we know what we're going to attack
all you have to do is find a piece that
can attack both the bishop and Rick at
the same time which move right and as
you can see the Rick can't move so it
obviously can't protect the bishop the
bishops on a black square so obviously
it can't protect the trick on a white
square and so that wins so that's
example one this is again a win for
white so the first thing to do if you're
white is to look for the unprotected
pieces what are they this time right and
it's wouldn't it's convenient in this
example that we already have a rook
lined up on both those pieces
the only problem as far as getting a
double attack goes our Knights in the
way between the bishop and our rook
right all right so that's gonna suggest
a knight move somewhere that would allow
us to attack the two pieces and if the
Black Knight moves naturally we'll take
the bishop now there's two possible
moves for the night see if you guys can
pick out the right move what's the right
move
for white so you want to retreat the
night to a safe spot there's really two
possibilities which of the two is the
correct move for what okay and what was
the other possibility that's right now
what's the difference between f3 and d3
for white as far as future moves go do
you see a drawback to the move you
suggested Knight to f3 yeah that would
lead to checkmate so what we can't we
couldn't take that night right away in
fact we wouldn't even be threatening it
but Knight to d3 blocks the rook and the
knights protected by a pawn so that's
stronger because it threatens rook takes
Knight right away right now there's one
other point that you need to keep in
mind after we play Knight to d3 he
obviously can't move his knight anywhere
we take the bishop right so the only
alternative is for him to protect the
knight right right right exactly
now another drawback tonight to f3 would
have been that we blocked the f2 pawn
and we wouldn't have the resource f3 to
drive the night away which you just
pointed out and which is how we're gonna
win this game
okay so we've established Knight to d3
black has no choice but to play f5 and
then the right move is to drive the
night away with a pawn if the knight
moves we take the bishop so far so good
right does black have any alternative
moves
besides moving the night yeah candidate
moves any moves at all besides moving
the night that would at least prevent
the immediate loss of a piece when we
move that pawn in on f2 to f3 we opened
up a line toward our King didn't we
check that's right and if we do Knight
takes Bishop then Knight takes Knight
and it looks like Black has gotten out
of his problem but let's go into it cuz
there's a trick here for white so the
best move for black is Bishop to c5 just
like you said no no King h1 doesn't work
because he does Knight - f - check we
have to do Knight takes he does Bishop
takes attacking our rook we moved the
rook he moves the bishop back and he's
saved to speak his piece so the right
move is Knight takes bishop ok Knight
takes bishop wait a minute there we go
black obviously has to take back now the
attack continues there's not two
unprotected pieces there's one
unprotected piece now right yeah that's
the knight on c5 what Square is it on
it's a black square do we have a piece
that can attack black squares what's
that okay now notice further that the
knight at c5 and the wreck and f8 are on
the same diagonal that's the black
diagonal how can we take advantage of
those facts to make a strong attacking
move for
and what do you think it is what are the
different bishop moves that white can
make check out all the possible bishop
moves which are that there's two moves
that actually threaten a black piece
under those two moves right okay now
let's look at the first one let's take a
quick look at Bishop to e3
that is a strong threat Bishop takes
Knight but black could move his knight
back somewhere couldn't he the other
thing is a black he could he would get
double pawns but he could play b6 and
protects the knight - right all right
and in a case we may have a better
position than black but we don't have an
outright win now let's look at the other
movie you suggested Bishop to g5 we
attack the rock that gains us a temple
or another move because he obviously has
to move the work right where can he move
the rook
see
okay let's take a look at work to dese
Evan you wouldn't move it behind a pawn
because then you wouldn't have any good
moves in the future okay
but at least on d7 he still he can he
defends his second row black second row
and he can move up to all the squares on
the file depending on what happens now
remember I told you that the black
knight on c5 and the rook on f8 are
lined up on the same died you know can
we attack both those pieces with another
bishop move notice that the square e
seven is protected by our work on a1
isn't it so we can move our Bishop to e7
and fork or attack the two pieces of the
rook on f8 and the knight and once we
move the bishop off our first row the
two rooks protect each other so there's
no pin by black so black moves the rook
we take the knight if he moves the
knight we take the rook and we win a
rook for a bishop five points for three
points but there's one other move for
black besides rook to e7 this is where
it gets really tricky can that rook on
d8 protect the knight and move away from
the bishop at the same time remember our
bishops on g5 we're doing this in our
head working that black work move to
protect the knight on c5
yeah I worked to d5
now if the bishop forks the other rook
and the knight the rook moves and it
looks like oh we can't do Bishop takes
Knight because he can answer it takes
Bishop right there's one last trick to
it so let's go to that position Bishop
to g5 work to d5 Bishop d7 rook to e8
okay
now White's problem he's within what a
couple moves of finishing and winning a
piece he's attacking the knight on c5
it's defended by the rook can he drive
the wreck away from d5 with any move
yeah that's the winning move
congratulations
c4 he can't go to e5 because our rook on
e 1 covers that square he can go back
and attack the bishop but the bishops
gonna move and take the night off the
board right yep so that's it that was
more complicated that was kind of a fun
example this is not a win of a piece in
this position it does show some possible
double attacks if the position isn't
played quite right for white and black
so we'll walk through up white starts
off he moves his Knight to e4 now what
does the knight attack from efore
there's two black up a piece and a pawn
that he can capture
so what's White's threat mariya what's
White's threat
Knight takes e5 or Bishop takes e5 okay
now that's true but black has some
counter-attacks now let's talk about
what black has notice that that black
bishop on d6 attacks the white pawn on
h2 and notice that the black Queen can
move from d8 to h4 where it would also
threaten the pawn at age 2 now the white
the white square black Bishop Bishop and
c8 it could at some point in the
position it could move itself to b7 and
see how it would be on that long
diagonal attacking the knight but beyond
the night it would attack the King
Knight 2 squared so if a bishop was at
b7 and attacked the King night the g2
square the pawn in front of the king
notice that it's possible if the white
Bishop wasn't at e3 the black Queen
could go to g5 maybe in the future and
the Queen and the bishop could attack
the point G to the pawn of G 2 okay so
those are the main possibilities now the
other possibility for white he may
decide that taking that pawn is too
risky the safe thing for white to do
would be to take the bishop you see
white sees an attack by two bishops and
a queen coming his way that attack is
gonna be pretty strong so the safe thing
for white is to get rid of the two
bishops by taking the black the bishop
on the black score at d6 now it's true
that that helps black in the sense of
the black can undoes weak double pawns
by
seven takes d6 but what white gains from
doing that is he's king side position is
safe so sometimes in chess you can't get
everything you want you have to go for
safety so this example let's walk
through what happens okay the first one
is look Black has the possibility right
off the bat of taking that pawn on h2
with check the King takes it now the
Queen comes up to h4 check attacks the
king and the knight there's our double
attack the King has to go back to g1 the
Queen takes e4 and the black looks like
black one a pawn but that's not as good
as it looks at first blush because he
has a pawn on c5 this is unprotected and
that black squared Bishop can just snap
it off then White's going to have three
pawns on the Queen side connected you
see that and black is going to have two
and remember a queen side pawn majority
in the ending can lead to a win because
you can get a passed pawn and it takes
black longer because and the white King
is on the King side he can stop any past
pawn that that's created over there so
the now white does take that pawn and
notice the bishop threatens the rook and
the Queen another double attack isn't it
this time the double attack isn't by the
bishop attacking two things bishop
attacking the rook on f8 and the Queen
attacking the Queen so there's no choice
but black has to do Queen takes Queen
Queen takes eetu
and then the rook takes e to now the
black rook has to move the only square
open is d8 now let's look at this
position objectively it were in an
ending black has the bishop on c8 that's
still in its initial position it is
undeveloped isn't it black has the
Bishop on c5 different color than the
black Bishop which is a white square
bishop but blacks Bishop on c5 is is
stronger and developed also notice that
because the bishops still on c8 the two
rooks aren't protecting each other it's
going to take black at least a move he's
got to move that bishop out of the way
before he can oppose rooks on the e-file
the other thing is White's rook on Queen
rook one can move over to be eight for
example and he can double roots on the
e-file and then black can't move a rook
over there to oppose rooks right then he
can't move his king the f8 to defend the
rook on EA Tabuk guards the f8 square so
what this amounts to is a better ending
with winning chances for white it's not
a clear win but white has better chances
will do one more move the best move for
white is to grab the seventh rank and
attack that pawn on c7 that pawn can't
be defended by a rook he can't do work
2d 7w
now he might try rook to b8 and
counter-attack our pond that's
undefended on b2 we won't go any further
than this black might be able to hold it
but the okay now let's look at a
different move so the first stripe I
black Bishop takes h2 check it was
pretty but it didn't really work now
let's look at another move for black
Bishop to b7 this is the might be a
better move notice he continued
developing another piece the bishop
moves to b7 whenever you can develop a
piece with a threat it's worth
considering the move so the bishop
threatens the knight and now the rooks
and Queen the bishop got out of the way
they all protect each other don't they
so white can't do anything in the e-file
because it's all protected so this is a
stronger now let's say okay now let's
take a look at Knight takes pawn it
looks like a good move because it
threatens that Bishop on b7 doesn't it
but remember I told you the bishop on b7
attacks that pawn on g2 remember that
and that the Queen could come up and
attack the pawn so Knight takes pawn
actually loses Bishop takes Knight that
safeguards our Bishop on b7 and it takes
the bishop from e3 to a square that
she's not protected and it opens up the
g5 square when the bishop was on a3 the
Queen couldn't go to g5 could it so now
the winning move
is Queen to g5 threatening Queen the G
to checkmate and the bishop at the same
time there's our double attack again the
theme of these examples there's no
defense to that okay now there's another
try there's another way to win the pawn
we just saw that Knight takes pawn
doesn't work how about if white does
Bishop takes pawn first what happens
that now it's a big difference now if
the bishop on b7 takes the knight we
don't do Queen takes Bishop the answer
is Bishop takes d6 and we attack the
work on f8 gaining a temple black has to
take our Bishop on d6 let's say he does
Queen takes well then we do Queen takes
pawn
I mean Queen takes bishop on e4 and were
a pawn up right so we're safe that would
work out good for us so the move for
black the possible move for black Bishop
on b7 takes e4 doesn't work for black
does it now we have to look at the other
possibility Bishop takes Bishop so let's
look at that and I'll bring it up on the
board okay so the only possible move is
Knight takes e5 now threatening mate
doesn't work as he can just take our
Bishop and win a piece right but the
same idea works
with a twist do you guys see the winning
move right Bishop takes g2 King takes
and now the Queen can come up with check
to the same square double attack and get
that night back and it's probably going
to be a
ting moves back somewhere and Queen
takes Knight that's probably a dry so
the conclusion we're back to the
original statement I made when the
Bishop attacks the knight what's the
safe move for white well better than
retreating it would be better to
liquidate the black the bishop on d6 so
Knight takes d6 now white doesn't black
doesn't have enough pieces to attack the
King side so the best move for black is
to undal the pawns see with our Bishop
on e3 black can't move Queen the g5
there's can't threaten mate he can't
move
from the black square d8 to c6 where the
bishop and queen are on the same
diagonal to g2 that's called a battery
by the way so he can't go there at least
not for couple moves and even if he got
his Queen to c6 we could just move our
queen up to g4 you see that and the
Queen would protect backwards to the G
to pawn and if the White Queen got to g4
we would have the threat Bishop to h6
threatening Queen takes Knight pawn
checkmate ourselves anyway this should
be a draw they have the same number of
pawns they have bishops of opposite
colors same number of Queens and rooks
so it should be a dry eye the computer
says that White has a slight advantage
though okay let's go on to the next
example
this one is real simple it starts out
with black making a blunder I won't have
you guess what the blender is but black
has the better position he has his rook
on his seventh rank white second rank so
that's a work I'm the seventh see how it
attacks all the squares along the second
row and he has a strong night on f4
attacking the white squares h3g to e2
and d3 now there defended by the bishop
so there's no checkmate or anything for
black but the other good thing about the
knight on f4 notice it's blocking the
pond on f3 that's an ideal situation for
a knight is to be blocking the
opponent's pawn and there are no pawns @
g2 or e2 to drive the night away and
there's no black square bishop to trade
the night away and there's no Knight to
trade the night away so that night is
never going to be driven off of f4 and
the knights protected by the work on f8
so the only way to and the only way to
drive that night away would be at both
rooks lined up on the 4th row for white
but that would have other drawbacks cuz
he would leave his back row undefended
and other things so black has the better
position even even has an extra pawn
he's got four pawns to three in this
example black gets greedy he sees
there's a pawn at h2
that's a double question mark move
what's the winning move for a wife
right double attack
check tacking king and rook or forking
the king and rook so that one's real
simple okay now this is a case where
there's all you have to do is find one
winning move for black it's one move
away take a few minutes and see if you
can find the winning move for black now
remember what I told you was all these
examples are double tax we want to find
two pieces that aren't defended does
anybody see two pieces with two white
pieces that aren't defended that's
definitely one it's undefended is there
another piece
this is a bit of a trick question let me
give you a hint notice that the black
rooks one of them is real strong on g8
it's attacking that pawn on g2 right
very strong rook the other work is
behind the night next to the king it's
on d8 it can't move anywhere except over
to the he could go to the e-file but
then it doesn't threaten anything
immediately anyway Black has one really
good rook in one work that's not bad but
it's just defensive the rook on d8 is
just defensive right now does anyone see
what that Rickon g8 is doing visa vie
the pawn on g2 that's right that pawn is
what what's the chest term pinned does a
pin pon effectively protect some other
piece it doesn't what piece is that pawn
it looks like it's protecting but it's
not really the knight on f3 now we have
our two unprotected pieces one of them
technically the pawn protects it but
because of the rook pin it's not an
effective protection so that's our two
pieces now do you see how to attack the
rook in the night at the same time with
what move right Queen to c3
now there's no way to protect the rook
the rooks worth more than the Knights of
the rook moves somewhere and then the
winning move as Queen takes Knight and
black one a piece right okay so so
sometimes you have to look a little
deeper into it these are not always they
easy to figure out okay let's look at
this position before I tell you who is
winning let's start with the white
pieces white has a serious problem
number one his knight on e4 is attacked
isn't it number two blacks queen has
penetrated into the middle of whites
position on g2 and the Queen on g2
threatens network on h1 with Queen takes
for a check right
okay so right off the bat the the rook
on h1 and the knight on e4 poses a real
problem for white now that white square
bishop on b5 it attacks a knight but the
Knights defended by a pawn isn't it yeah
so that Bishop really isn't doing much
for white is it he doesn't have time to
do Bishop takes Knight because Queen
takes rook check the King moves he could
take in her work on a1 or take the
knight with the Queen what a lovely
choice to have notice that that bishop
is what remember our theme is
unprotected pieces so that Bishop is
unprotected right now we already said
that the knight in the work on h1 are
unprotected is there another unprotected
piece and not the Queen the Queen's
unprotected but because she can move in
all directions she's pretty good at
fighting off an attacker
there is another unprotected piece what
is it
right now is there a way that black
could move and attack that unprotected
bishop on b5 in the rook on a1 at the
same time right then the threat would be
Queen takes rook check and queen takes
bishop and white can't meet both of them
okay
but White has more media problems than
black taking his queen Knight bond he
has to protect his rook and protect his
knight at the same time there's only one
move that'll do that what's that what
worked to g1 doesn't quite work because
there's Queen takes Knight when you have
two pieces attacked you have to see if
one of the pieces can move and protect
the other do you see that possibility
okay let's look at that that's one
possibility is there a way that black
can eliminate that Knight taking away
the protection of the rook no you say
rook takes F to immediately wins Queen
takes Queen takes rook check King moves
or Queen back any way we would have won
a whole night because we took a knight
she took our rook but then we took that
work so we're Knight up easy win so
Knight to f2 doesn't work it's there
another night move okay Knight to g3 now
we solved our immediate problem we saved
our knight on e4 and protected our rook
but remember I told you about that other
the other two unprotected pieces so
what's the winning move for black now
right cuz that thread is still there
isn't it and we have two unprotected
pieces were threatening Queen take
strict check and Queen takes bishop and
there's no defenses there rook what yeah
there isn't one okay so so much for that
one okay
the author has white make a mistake so
there's nothing for you guys to decide
yet black is gonna win this game but I
have to make the mistake first and that
mistake is this pawn on e5 moving to e6
it looks like it might be good and it
blocks that white square Bishop on c8
but it's not a good move does anyone see
the winning move that attacks two pieces
at one time for black let's talk about
the black position for a minute oh you
gotta have an idea what's your idea
that's a great move it attacks the
knight on f3 with the pawn doesn't it
but the bishops protected by the knight
on c3 good point so the threat is not
Queen takes bishop but Knight takes
bishop first which I think you saw so
Knight takes Bishop Knight takes Knight
Queen takes Knight we win our piece so
he can't save white can't save this
position because if he moves the knight
then we win the piece just like you said
so that's all there was to it but you
had to see that the pawn move in most of
our examples we moved to Queen or a
bishop and we forked the King and
another piece well this is a little more
subtle in this case we moved a pawn that
opened up the line of the Queen on the
bishop and we get our double attack from
the pawn attacking the knight and the
Queen and Knight attacking the bishop so
it's a little different than what we've
seen so far but it works just as well
okay this one again the author has in
this case black makes a blunder a bad
move setting up a double attack black
takes the pawn on f6 you guys figure out
the winning move for whites it's a
couple moves you got to see a couple
moves here
remember our theme is double attacks
what's the unprotected black piece
that's the key to this c5 you got to
figure out a way to attack that Bishop
and another piece at the same time
anyone want to guess what the solution
is okay we'll go on
notice that the knight can take the
bishop the night and rook or on the
bishop so the Queen can't take the pawn
takes right and the pawn moving opens up
a line that white can check the black
keygen with what h5 which conveniently
hits c5 at the same time that's our
double attack so there it is now just
for the record books
let's go back this is a standard opening
does anyone know what this opening is
called
have you ever heard of the max Lang
attack it comes out of a at Kyoko piano
- night's game comes out of a to night's
defense
yeah I'm not totally sure but the what's
the right the right move for black is
not to take the pawn but to move the
Queen to d5 where it protects the bishop
now white gets that pawn on g7 and the
rout comes over to try to capture it
back and it just goes on for a long
number of moves from here White has a
strong attack but black has defensive
resources if you have memorized the
opening you should be able to survive as
black called the max Lang attack okay
well we got five more minutes so let's
try to get through it at least to one or
two more I'm going to get rid of the
notation so you can't read it
what's there's a winning move for white
there is a double attack not necessarily
a pieces
what's the winning move for white Mario
you got a guess okay
yeah that would force the Queen back and
protect the work pawn at the same time
but you're onto a good idea is there
another way to attack that that pawn on
e6 is an unprotected pawn is there
another way to attack it yeah that might
be worth what I'll see you threatening
after Queen e2 which pawn what else
you're threatening each six at the same
time you got three pieces and black only
has two that's our double attack in this
case that's a double attack on pause so
that's the answer
Queen to e2 and there's no way black and
defend both pawns okay black wins
now what would what would you has better
attacking chances white or black I told
you black wins so naturally black has
better but why does black have better
attacking chances
go ahead
what's your threat what's the threat
after Bishop to e2 what's blacks threat
and King to h1 and then what's the move
right you're threatening checkmate so
you can throw that Bishop that's in the
way of the rooks away but you went to
the right square
you attacked White's unprotected piece
what was that b5 so this is a very
strong move it threatens checkmate along
with the rooks on the G file and it
threatens Bishop takes Bishop on b5
unprotected there's your double attack
and because of the checkmate three
threat there's no answer to it there is
no answer
that's the obvious answer
well
look how weak your kingside position is
but after we do Bishop takes Bishop we
can eventually we can do Quan takes pawn
pause it we can probably sacrifice the
rook or it takes pawn Knight Queen takes
check and follow up with Queen to G to
checkmate maybe something like that okay
anyway that should do it for tonight
thanks for coming
[Music]